[Music]
so welcome everyone to a
high-performance computing a session on
Google cloud my name is Bill Magro I'm
Chief Technologist fight for
high-performance computing at Intel and
I've the pleasure to have with me today
Peter McShane from apps broker and Bill
knits Berg from altair there in the
corners and we'll be we working through
this together so what we plan to cover
today in the session is I'm going to
talk about what Intel is doing to power
HPC in the cloud through our CPUs and
our activity is working closely with
Google and with the ecosystem but that's
not enough and so we're going to
transition then to Bill and he's going
to talk to you about how you alter is
working to really make it easy to get
access to HPC in the cloud by delivering
appliances essentially a pass layer and
access to the applications that matter
and then finally finally peter is going
to tell you about a center of excellence
that we've put together that's going to
make it a lot easier for you to come and
experience HPC in the cloud and do it
with very low risk and low cost to
understand how to take advantage of the
value we're going to talk about today so
let's dive right in so first of all I'd
like to just talk about our
collaboration with Google we have a
long-standing about 15-year
collaboration with Google and it started
with in providing feedback and helping
us shape the features and our processors
over the years we've delivered six
generations of custom CPUs to Google and
they were in fact the first to offer our
latest processor generation platform
skylake also known as the xeon scalable
processor family so it's very exciting
to have so much innovation the cloud and
the earliest access and as you just
heard in the keynote and was announced
recently we're now going to be launching
instances with Google that actually use
Intel's obtained data center memory
octane DC to give very very high
capacity at much lower cost for
in-memory workloads that demand that and
so if you want to go over to regime
skillern session or our cloud computing
GM she's going to be talking a lot more
about that in the next hour look up the
Intel session so Intel Xeon processors
are at the heart of the Google cloud
obviously performance is foundational
and there's a
that we've put in to our latest
generation skylake to drive performance
I'll tell you about that later and show
you some of the results in terms of
security your data security is paramount
and Intel processors have things such as
the AES ni instructions which actually
accelerate the encryption decryption
calculations and computations that
protect your data that's an example of
something that's in our CPUs and always
advancing to give you high performance
at high security and finally the
virtualization features and our
processors are really sitting underneath
a lot of the capability of both the
security and the flexibility and the
agility that allows you to to share
essentially a common resource in the
cloud and do it safely and securely so
clicking down the level into high
performance computing I'd like to talk
about what HPC is first sometimes you
talk to people and H they're new to HPC
sometimes they have very different
definitions at Intel we think of HPC is
an activity that really has three
characteristics the first one is the
purpose of the calculation is actually
to gain some insight you're trying to
learn something there's an intellectual
product the second characteristic is it
has to be a demanding workload it's not
low performance computing this is high
performance computing and the third
characteristic which i think is really
important is when you appropriately
apply more resources to the problem you
actually get a more valuable result so
think of one of these examples like
weather forecasting you could do a
weather forecast on your phone but you
get a 12 hour forecast and maybe 30 days
that has zero value but if you can run
that thing in in three hours and now
determine that something's going to
happen you need to evacuate some people
or change your plans I can have
tremendous value financial value and
just personal value and those examples
there are many of them across many
fields that they do high-performance
computing and it may be surprising to
you but we think of data analytics and
machine learning a lot of that actually
is the high-performance computing
workload and if you apply that those
three tests you'll see why so why are
people thinking about high performance
for high-performance computing some
people think it's a bit of an oxymoron
use AI high-performance computing is
about supercomputers right well if you
go to any supercomputing site what
you'll find is they have some very large
applications and workloads that are
driving the the characteristics and the
size of the machine but they have many
many smaller workloads that that could
actually run somewhere else so it's
still HPC
not every workload needs that machine
necessarily those machines though tend
to be completely full 100% utilization
and there's always a backlog and as soon
as the queue gets shorter engineers
scientists whoever's using that thing
are putting more jobs in so there's
always this pent up demand and so one of
the main reasons people are looking to
the cloud is because some of their
workloads can run well in the cloud and
they can manage those demand searches
and by taking some of the workloads that
maybe aren't demanding the on-premise
resources and putting them in the cloud
they actually make their own friend the
system even more valuable while it stays
full
there's also getting access to new
technologies like I mentioned earliest
access to skylake in the cloud and also
R&D collaboration think of teams all
around the world rather than shipping
data back and forth we take advantage of
the tremendous network that Google cloud
has and then enables people to
collaborate much more easily than
they've been able to in the past so how
do you decide what workloads should fit
in the cloud there's really two
characteristics the first one is do you
trust the cloud and I would argue that
in the past people felt that the cloud
maybe wasn't as secure and as safe as
keeping things at home I think those
perceptions are changing some of the
best security in the world is in the
cloud so there's this this boundary of
public cloud but it's rising at the
results of that in terms of technical
characteristics as I said there's a wide
range of workloads that run in HPC and
any of them could run on a dedicated HPC
system or a supercomputer but many of
them over on the left where they don't
necessarily need to scale as far they
don't need as tight coupling for message
passing which is the predominant way
that high-performance computing
applications run these are great fit and
so you see in industries like finance
and genomics that's where things start
or in manufacturing I show them on the
boundary where some of the early
calculations to do design studies have
done in the cloud and final studies for
noise vibration harshness combustion car
crash simulation and safety are run
still on a traditional HPC system so
finding the right workloads is key and
putting those in the cloud so behind HPC
in the cloud and behind the Google cloud
we have the Intel Xeon scalable
processor family this is our latest
generation codename skylake and we drove
a lot of innovations into this processor
specifically to meet the needs of
high-performance
computing workloads they very broad
benefits but HPC was one of the main
drivers an example is moving from the
previous generations ring architecture
to connect the course to a dual
two-dimensional mesh there's also
tremendous cash enhancements the
addition of avx-512 instructions what
allows us to do twice as many flops per
clock tick floating-point operations we
increase the memory bandwidth by gender
by a factor of two over the previous
generation and finally we increase the
number of cores and the efficiency of
hyper-threading and as a result people
are able to run much more dense
calculations on a single CPU so you're
seeing many more virtual machines
virtual CPUs inside of a VM now are
possible so where are these available
Google's been tremendously aggressive in
getting these out and so I think this
slide is already out of date since we
made it just a few weeks ago there were
13 regions google is adding the Skylink
instances all around the world so if you
want to use these all you have to do is
say the minimum CPU and and specify this
family in fact Bill will talk about that
a bit in his section and you can get
access to these and try out about and
see how well they do for your own
workload because at the end of the day
that's what matters but I do want to
show you some examples from some of our
customers and what they're saying
I think Descartes lab is a really
interesting interesting company they're
mining one petabyte of satellite imagery
from NASA from the last 40 years to look
at what's going on and and out of the
satellite data correlate it to the
history of the food supply in the world
and using it to predict crop yields
right this impacts the financial
services markets it impacts food
security around the world this is an
application of high performance
computing machine learning and obviously
very very big data and they've just in
this move to the latest generation saw
40% uptick almost in their performance
and you can see other examples where
people are seeing almost 2x especially
in the life sciences area the biotech
companies at the right so some date card
is actually has a session tomorrow if
you want to hear more about their
experience and go look at it
so a lot of this performance does come
to you quite naturally if you've
modernized your code but I do want to
put one caveat out there and say if you
haven't modernized your code you're just
counting on the processor to make things
faster you may be missing out so this is
an example from financial services of a
binomial tree options calculation and
you can see there's a hundred and 30x
performance difference over the seven
years that comes from someone who
actively optimized the code versus
someone who didn't so you need to thread
your code you need to vectorize your
code you need to work with the Intel
compilers that unleash the performance
of this process this processor otherwise
you could be leaving a hundred x
performance on the table this is a this
is a synthetic benchmark but we see it
in real applications as well so it is
work but we have things to help you out
with that so what does Intel do to help
you
we're talking about modernizing your
code well the first thing we need to do
is provide a development methodology for
your high performance computing
applications that allows you to
understand where you're leaving
performance on the table and then go
chase it down so some things we
recommend the first one out of this
parallel studio XE is use optimized
libraries these have been hand tuned for
latest processors they're out there
today they're launched with the
processors so if you're using math
libraries you're getting the performance
many many applications and HPC do that
the second one is compile our compilers
are updated well ahead of the release of
a processor and allow you to actually
update your application it'll still run
on previous generations but it'll be
optimized for the new generation be
ready to go when it comes out we have
analysis tools again that point you to
not only where you're leaving
performance on the table but also tell
you how you can extract that performance
by making recommendations around
vectorization recommendations around
threading and even projecting for you
the type of performance that you could
get our adviser tool and finally our
vtune tool shows you the results of your
analysis and whether or not you got the
performance you expected and if not why
not by using the hardware counters that
exist in our processors and some very
advanced analysis techniques and finally
performance is nothing if your
application isn't correct and anyone
who's done parallel programming knows
that
multithreading vectorization if you do
them incorrectly you can get the wrong
results so we have a whole suite of
tools that analyzed and will help you
find those types of problems
automatically which are tremendous
productivity boosters so this is exactly
what we recommend for on Prem systems
it's exactly what you need to do in the
cloud so we've put a lot of effort in
with Google to make sure that these
tools are run and run well in the cloud
so please check out the parallel studio
XE if you're going to be running
applications in the cloud that you write
yourself so the last thing I want to say
before I hand it over to Bill is I've
talked about CPUs I've talked about the
motivations but there's there's a big
distance between coming up from the
bottom and having the infrastructure
interfaces that you get through Google
Cloud and what HPC users and HPC
applications expect coming from the top
and the link between those two worlds to
make it possible for you to continue
using your on-prem resources but put
those same applications perhaps with
different input datasets in the cloud is
consistency so Intel has been working
with the industry for over a decade to
document a standard cluster architecture
and it's been adopted very broadly i'm
Altair's been one of our great partners
in this and their appliances actually
implement this and as a result are very
compatible not only with their own
applications but from applications
across the industry so with that I'd
like to introduce bill mitts Berg who
will take you through some of those
usability things and making HPC work in
the cloud thanks Bill hey and now I get
to say thanks Bill let me just start by
telling you that I I believe we believe
it Altair that HPC improves people's
lives and and you've heard from Bill
about the different places but I'm when
I think about high-performance computing
I think about you know making child
safety seats safer making airplanes
lighter to save fuel making you know my
cell phone not break when I drop it it's
it's about making people's lives better
it's why I'm here it's why I do what I
do it's why I really love working at
Altair and a tiny bit about Altair we're
kind of unique in that I'm gonna talk
about the middleware layer which is
trying to make HPC more accessible and
more easy
that's PBS works and I'm gonna talk
about that that's where I live in Altair
but Altair also has two other groups
they're actually bigger than mine one
makes applications physics applications
that actually do high-performance
computing so the folks who are actually
designing you know a new outside of a
phone or something or a new car bumper
or something will use those applications
and then we actually have a team of
people around the world hundreds of
people around the world who are just
engineers actually using these tools
using our middleware doing stuff it's
it's this fantastic feedback loop we
have openings if you want to never leave
so PBS works is really software for
high-performance computing that makes
high-performance computing sort of more
natural more easy and I'll give you a
couple examples and I have a couple
videos so we focus on making things sort
of easier for administrators and
managers to control high performance
computing and that's both giving
visibility about what's going on but
also sort of setting things up doing all
the you know the nitty gritty that you
have to do
connecting to clusters but also sort of
connecting up into into a cloud or
actually just running in the cloud I'll
say more about that but we also focus on
making things easier for actual
engineers and researchers when they're
using stuff and I'll show you what the
vision looks like for that and then
finally we haven't that's sort of Altair
access so the name of the tool and then
we have a tool called PBS Pro which I
won't really talk about which optimizes
stuff once it actually gets there tiny
bit more about control so control is the
control center the that we put in front
of it's a GUI it's a web-based GUI for
HPC administrators that lets you sort of
a single pane of glass and lets you
configure deploy monitor handles
bursting for you connecting your private
HPC supercomputer up up to something
like Google cloud gives you real time
monitoring reporting really nice feature
that we've added is a workload simulator
and I don't have a demo of this so I'll
just say it you can actually take so one
of the problems in high-performance
computing these are really complicated
systems even if you're using even if
you're all cloud it's a conflict it's a
complicated infrastructure with a
complicated workload and if you want to
optimize exactly what you're using and
how you're using it it's nice to be able
to
say hey here's what I did last quarter
could you tell me if I changed a few
things around if I switched to you know
if I used larger memory knows what will
you know how fast would things have got
done would we have had faster turnaround
and so we have a simulator built-in that
lets you ask and answer that question
and then cloudbursting on the access
side we really have been trying to
reimagine what engineers do so I'm a
geek I'm a nerd and so I live in command
line I'm happy to install Linux although
I haven't done in too many years but I'm
happy to really and what we found though
is is that great at the very very high
end people really know what they're
doing they're experts but if you want to
take high-performance computing which by
the way my definition of
high-performance computing is is taking
computing up to the absolute maximum
performance level you can not quite you
know just to where it almost doesn't
work but right up to the edge so so
performance is paramount and so at that
level you have a lot of really smart
people they don't mind doing a lot of
stuff but if you want to make that
available to other people down lower
what we found is that the engineers of
today are not as happy doing all the
nitty-gritty stuff and in fact if you
can give an interface this is crazy I
don't believe it but I actually believe
it that sounds crazy if you could give
an interface that requires it's zero
Linux shell or zero little bits about IT
you can actually attract like a hundred
times more people in terms of just
learning curve so if you can get nobody
to have to type ls' or CP you actually
get this huge extra set of people and so
that's our vision and let me just show
you what PBS access the vision for PBS
access and I don't know this is gonna
work I should introduce this it's just a
Windows this is a Windows desktop of how
you might actually access a Google compl
at forum Google compute platform running
a high-performance computing application
and the video is really what a day and
level 58 seconds in the life of an
engineer to run a high-performance
application ok so that we're gonna have
to do from here I think let's see what
we got
hmm Wow I don't know how to play the
video do we mm-hmm
any guy no okay we're gonna go to
YouTube apparently but I don't have that
screen oh there we go wait well I'm
gonna do this it's gonna mess everything
up we're gonna start it from the
beginning okay regular desktop
I'm a regular engineer usually I just
have my files in front of me I'm right
clicking on a file it actually gives me
this new option process with which
basically means run some
high-performance computing I'm gonna
pick op destruct which is a structural
engineering optimization code that's it
that right click is everything I need to
do you can see in the upper right it's
actually uploading some files off to the
high-performance computing system or
cloud it's actually submitting a job for
me automatically
the little file icon actually says hey
stuff was uploading and hopefully by the
time I finish this sentence that little
file icon will say everything is now
downloaded nope okay okay job has
completed and it will automatically
bring those files back so what did I not
do
I didn't log in anywhere I didn't type
any shell I didn't do anything and we're
actually doing some Google i/o and I
don't know how to get back to this can
we go back here no wait wait the witch
ah hey hey okay thank you there's gonna
be two videos sorry uh awesome
[Music]
so the vision is basically effectively
nearly invisible high-performance
computing so that's gonna actually
attract a huge quantity of more people
who don't have access to - where it's
computing and that lets you get to your
local local system or cloud at Altera
like I said we have this broad range of
applications and one of the things that
you want to do in high-performance
computing is you want to perform as fast
as possible so these are physics
applications that do the work as any and
one of the nice things about our
partnership was Intel we get you know
access to Intel processors and we can
actually do sorts of meet tests and we
did one of those tests with radios a
crash code and found that actually it
runs 1.8 times faster on Intel skylake
and just there's two examples I'll give
up how you can actually choose Intel
skylake because you know if you want to
get performance if you're doing
high-performance give you thing you want
to so one is when you're creating an
instance on Google Cloud you can just
pick the you can just pick I want
skylake and for that you're gonna
actually get skylake you'll get this 1.8
times faster but how do you actually get
you know most high performance computing
today is actually done in private
systems on supercomputers and and even
though it's the most leading-edge sort
of newest work that people working on
the organizations are a little slow to
adopting so most of the work actually
still happens in-house on private
clusters and we're just connecting the
cloud and the way that we're connecting
to the cloud is through cloud bursting
if you haven't heard it before all that
means is building a hybrid system a lot
of works happening locally when you have
specific work that fits you actually
create an instance on the cloud to run
that local work and with the PBS works
tools we make that really seamless and
let me show you I'm going to skip this
slide
the interest of time here let me show
you how that's done and I'll just show
the second video which I'm gonna have
trouble with it which is why I'm
skipping a slide so this is the last
video I have and let me see if I can do
this by clicking on the right hand side
here let's see if this just works ha it
works so with with PBS works we actually
let you build an appliance on the cloud
with a few clicks so this is the
interface inside of PBS cloud IO which
is the software-as-a-service version of
PBS control you just say hey I want to
build an appliance say a few things
about what you want you pick Google
compute platform because we're here you
can pick the region where you want to
run and then actually for the appliance
in this case we're building a hyper
works appliance you'll actually pick the
kinds of instances you want in here I'm
actually picking a 90/60 few instance so
that'll get me skylake we automatically
fill in for you all of this crazy stuff
you need in order to actually do the
system ministration stuff you can of
course change it because you have to and
that's it the beautiful interface I
showed you on the Windows desktop also
is available as a web interface it's
just as beautiful but maybe not as
simple because but if you want to submit
a job through the web instead of through
the desktop more or less the same thing
you pick the application you want you
say here's the file I want fill in any
kind of not default that that that hat
don't sorry any anything that's not
defaulted and click Submit you can
actually get a lot more access through
the web about what's happening if you
need to yeah so you can actually find
out what's going on you can check the
files as they're local as they're
running on supercomputing Center you can
check the files actually if you've
bursted the cloud you can actually see
the files of the running job while it's
there you can get all sorts of job
attributes um perhaps one of the the
very neat things that you can do through
this interface I don't know my timing
perfect is you can also do remote
visualization which means you can take
something like a Chromebook here with no
memory and you can submit a job
a graphics job that's gonna use say you
know 256 gigabytes of memory and all
sorts of huge powerful stuff and you can
say please run this job in the cloud but
I want you to stream the bits back to my
back in my browser so that I can
actually do the work no matter where I
am and it's as simple as sort of while I
was talking what you saw there you just
say here's what I want to run I want to
run on the cloud we do all the
orchestration behind the scenes we set
everything up and you can run huge and
fantastic large yeah sorry about that
bicyclist fantastic large simulations
even from your you know even from a
really small device and with that I'm
gonna turn it over to the next speaker
Peter thank you come on let's give bill
a big round of applause it's so exciting
technology we've seen here folks
who would have thought a year ago we
could even do some of the things that
we're doing that it's possible that Bill
Magro is talking about in terms of HPC
some of the orchestration tools the bill
from Altair has been telling us in terms
of orchestration it are incredible but
I'm here to ask a question and help see
how we can answer that which is given
all this amazing technology why is so
little of it still being used less than
10% of this great tech lab technology is
being used at the moment by people that
require a HPC and I have a personal
interest in this as well in that once
upon a time I was doing a lot of
electromagnetic lynnie induction
research and one of my biggest
frustrations was waiting and how in
today's environment can we afford to
wait and that's something that we really
need to solve and really need to solve
quickly I think there's a lot of
business people in the audience they
don't really realize what's possible
that's what we want to we want to help
enable so I'm Peter McShane good morning
everybody
I represent a company called apps broker
and before we help answer that question
let's tell you a bit more about apps
broker apps broker is an extraordinary
organized
we are the biggest Google practice in
Europe the biggest we've got 150 staff
spread across the UK spread across
Romania and unusually we also have what
we call customer experience officers in
France in the Alps and we earn our own
island where we do customer
collaboration and team building so we do
things differently so differently that
if you wanted to spot an apps broker
person just look for people wearing
these red jackets because we were told
it was cold in San Francisco man we are
sweating
so yeah very easy to spy on and just to
give you a sense of what apps broker is
all about is for the some of those who
were listening to the solution selling
workshop where we're doing things
differently in financial services is you
know we're helping apply regulation or
helping banks enable sort of method
regulation and opening up all sorts of
new data sources they didn't know
existed we're doing similar things in
retail in supply chain optimization in
the retail space but one of the things
that we're really excited about is all
this infrastructure that Bill magros
talking about how do we start creating
real time innovation how do we start
getting results now and that's why one
of the things that we've we're doing now
is we've just partnered we set up a
partnership with Intel and Google to
form what we call the extreme cloud
center of excellence now this is an
amazing facility with three pioneering
organizations in cloud coming together
to try and answer that question that we
talked about earlier firstly know
delivering something that is not just
cheaper but faster and also way easier
to consume cheaper because Google Cloud
is currently offering the lowest TCO in
terms of changing what is normally in
super computes a big capex expense into
an optics expense with some of the
greatest technology from Intel I mean
without a doubt Intel Xeon scalable
technology is some of the best in the
industry at the moment but what they're
doing as well is Bill talked about power
studio and some of the maths Colonel
libraries as well these are really
making it a bit easier to use but where
we're putting the wrapping on that is
trying to bring people into this people
in terms of apps broker experts that
have been working with Google for 12
years on implementing Google platform so
we understand Google but leveraging the
best of Intel and Google resources as
well now why is they important because
one of the reasons why a lot of the
change isn't happening is because it's
about creating business awareness
business leaders don't know what's
possible it's also around creating
technical awareness helping people
understand what performance is really
possible people that typically have
their own platforms and also it's very
much around creating a change in culture
as well one where people are thinking
about using new features all the time
and not standalone static systems so we
talked earlier about extreme cloud bill
mentioned you know the use cases in in a
number of industries and yes right now
using the Google cloud platform for big
companies means you can do far more
processing far more analysis far more
simulations you can get really good
insights at very low cost the challenge
you're we're hearing from a lot of
customers though is well if we start
adopting the cloud how are we going to
have a roadmap of innovation and and
that's something that Google is
answering with the Intel relationship
you heard today or yesterday about the
Apache pass feature set that's been put
onto the Intel platform and there's many
many more things coming and what's great
about Google is they're adopting that
quickly so that's a big tick the second
thing though waring from customers is
this is great but what about security
because despite the fact that Google's
whole cloud platform was built with
security you know as part of the DNA
people don't really know how to use it
properly a lot of them have system
administrators that haven't really had
the experience of deploying it's scaled
in cloud yet a lot of them don't know
how to do sandboxing a lot of them also
concerned about Layton sees because some
of them have very constrained systems
where the infrastructure needs to be
pretty close to the data so that's why
we set up echo
eko is a physical facility the first one
we've got is in the UK we plan to put
dots all over the map and what it's
doing is allowing organizations to
really get a sense of the power of the
Google cloud platform in terms of HPC
now how we're doing that is we're not
just providing access to Google cloud on
people what we're doing is real hybrid
performance benchmarking what that means
is we've got a facility with an in-house
intel on-premise platform as well as the
Google cloud so customers can start
seeing which Klerk workloads to make
sense to put on the cloud and which
workloads make sense to leave on Prem
because we're not saying that Google
cloud right now is the answer to all the
workloads there are some workloads that
are very or many workloads that are very
sensitive they have to be run on on
print systems but this this offers an
opportunity to really start testing that
in different environments what we also
have is is partnerships with some of the
specialized RSV so we talked about
Altair and and if you can wander down to
Moscone West to the where the Intel
stand is we're actually showing some of
the work we're doing with Intel and it's
sorry with Altair and PBS there and how
can we start optimizing orchestration
how can we start doing it across several
different applications what you also get
with with the echo environment is direct
access to some of the key staff in Apps
broker Google and Intel who are
constantly looking at some of the new
feature sets and really start enabling a
sort of a hybrid cloud environment start
doing real sound boxing one of the cool
things as well as wherever we learning
we're turning those into tools so in
terms of orchestration we're looking at
how we start doing consistent deployment
of VMs and containers at scale which
enables this we're also looking at tools
for cost management as well because one
of the things that customers are
concerned about when moving into the
cloud is how do I contain the cost how
does this not get out of control it's
great that I'm innovating at speed but
how do I avoid this getting out of
control and that's the value that we're
providing as part of the echo
environment now in order to to to
realize scale one of the things we
recognize is that you need to have a
proof of concept initially and we call
our proof
concert process three steps to
extraordinary now what this does is
helps both business leaders and
technical and technical fokin
organizations get a sense of what the
business case is get a sense of what the
benchmark you what the performances and
what and also what the roadmap should
look like for your organization so as
part of that we've established what we
call the apse Booker blueprint which
really helps work with you to get a
sense of exactly how your HP C is
performing at the moment and from that
moving that into a workshop environment
within the echo environment where we can
start doing some option earing start not
just doing whiteboards in terms of what
workloads should go in the right in
which place what kind of orchestration
is possible but actually testing that
real time so now you have an opportunity
within a lab environment to start
sandboxing properly across both on-prem
and off prim it's not trying different
types of orchestration and the results
of these three steps thought
extraordinary process is effectively a
business case which gives you the cost
benefits gives you the performance
benefits which workloads perform which
don't and also gives you a roadmap now
that's pretty critical for customers and
in fact somebody that we're working with
live right now is a European hedge fund
there is an immense demand in buy-side
financial services in terms of quants to
start up taking advantage of google
cloud and a massive demand but one of
the challenges that they keep on facing
is well how do we make this secure how
do we start actually using the capacity
in the right way for different types of
workloads
you've got Kwan's that are doing
algorithms on significant amounts of
external data significant amounts of
internal data who currently are
constrained to I mean constraint to
develop new algorithms or or constrained
because algorithms take too long to run
on systems this means millions of
dollars millions of dollars for these
organizations and so what we're doing is
working with with one of the larger
headphones to to look at firstly setting
up a hybrid data set up so mimicking
what they need in the future which is
probably in a bit of an on-premise as
well as a cloud platform
start establishing provisioning helping
them to start provisioning a scale both
on Prem and off Prem helping to do
setups and tear downs as quickly as
possible also reproduce the third-party
environments bring the is visa into the
mix you know in the same way we talked
about out tear and crash testing we're
gonna do the same in the Kwan space
bring everybody into the environment
because we don't know all the answers
but if we bring everybody in we're gonna
get the right answers and one of the
things that we're looking as well with
this particular fund is how you know
with the workload manager you can start
allocating workloads between different
types of environment and what's exciting
is that the moment people start
recognizing the potential is they start
looking at some of the other Google
products such as tensorflow and cloudy I
and look at well hey we can use these to
create whole new models this is the
exciting thing about when people start
culturally recognizing the art of the
possible through the second environment
and one of the other things that we've
helped the hedge fund organizations is
we showed the market cost control
dashboard which really takes a view of
what you're likely spend might be and
starts notifying and messaging people in
terms of you know when when things may
run out so it gives you control over
that spend as well so in summary I think
you know we're at an inflection point
all this technology that bill and Bill
spoke about earlier is fantastic but
it's really usable now and I think
coming back to the question answered
asked at the beginning of the
presentation is why are you waiting
why are you waiting to innovate if
you're running a design business if you
need insights why are you waiting the
time is now and certainly if you can
make your way down to the Intel stand in
Moscone West we'd love to talk to you
we'd love to see how we could
potentially do a proof-of-concept with
your organization and start making this
real thank you very much
[Music]